but you really look lovely oh thank you
so much yeah you I wore a short skirt to
show off my legs thank you so much I
have dances legs you have dancers legs
yes my grandma always told me this
because we had the same bodies my
grandma and I and I inherited her body
aha she would tell me what to do with my
body and she said that I should show my
legs off as much as possible Oh your
legs off as much as possible okay well I
was working for me you look gorgeous I
God thank you so much it's a very very
wise yes so what I have is an apple body
type my grandma and I so what I'm alone
okay they talk about it in women's
magazines a lot so what that means is
that you have little stick legs
mm-hmm like this and then you carry your
weight around the middle which is really
great so means you can wear short skirts
as much as you want and you just know
you're gonna die of heart disease
turning yeah a charming thing to say
because the weight really can gesture
it will eventually congest my heart
until I perish okay that's how I'm gonna
go unless I get murdered or an accident
yeah yeah this is you know I gotta say
you've thought of every contingency yeah
what what a lovely outlook on life you
have yeah cuz some people don't know how
they're gonna die and that sucks for
them yeah but you've got it pretty much
worked out to one of three ways
congratulations
you